most of you are not scared to fail for
yourself you're scared to fail and then
somebody else that you care about is
judging you so literally you're just
scared to fail I mean if you want to go
deep with me I'll go deep
it's who are you scared to fail in front
of and my question is yeah I'll do high
hustle and stop being a [ __ ] in a
temple I want to be where you are I have
a job that I absolutely love and of
course I want to get into doing my own
thing doing my own blog starting my own
hustle and I have this and I know it
stems from a fear of failure but I have
this really hard time I get like
crippled when it comes to like execute
the people that are scared to fail stay
within a comfort zone and can only hit a
certain level like I need you to look me
in my face and tell me what do you want
it
I think what's holding you back is what
you think other people are gonna say
about it
what's locking you some I don't know
other people's POV yes and for one man
for how do I just I can I know I can be
where is it like Paris is it who are the
other people yeah man
got to have that Real Talk cuz you've
already given it to me that it's the
fear of failure now the question becomes
to whom I'd go talk to that person up
front go in the [ __ ] face and be like
this is what I'm doing and like [ __ ] you
for judging me
my friends I'm telling you something
right now I'm desperately excited to
fail in front of you good you know the
craziest part is long-term I'm gonna win
and I just need to make sure if I fail
on this step that your response to me
doesn't crush me to never let me have a
second at-bat deep down you've seen the
movies that parent
normally respect you more for doing it
the best practical advice I've ever
given in this scenario and it works over
and over you sit down you look them in
the face to say I'm about to do this and
the only reason I haven't done it for
the last year is I don't want to let you
down because entrepreneurship is a
crapshoot and I'm not sure if I'm gonna
win but I don't really give a [ __ ] what
you think and B I'm going to learn from
it and see battle scars are attractive